Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
The boys just announced
the next new series called The Boys Mexico
So I'll explain what's going on, how it connects
with the boys Season for season 5, along with Gen V
season 2. Homelander sure is going to be busy
having to fly all over the place.
Just a laser people to death and squish them like bugs.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Of course, I will do episode videos
when it does premiere, probably around
2025, maybe 2026 at the rate they're going.
So really, this would be taking place
after like the boys season five.
but you probably saw the news in your feeds recently
the boys Mexico is like the next new series to come
from the main show Eric Kripke
and the people from the main show
are working with Diego Luna,
who most of you remember from somewhere.
He's been in a bunch of stuff, but most people
remember him more recently from Star Wars, and
I believe they're releasing
and or season two next year and Gael Garcia Bernal,
who is Marvel's Werewolf by Night at the moment
they're supposed to star in the series,
but they didn't say who their characters would be in
because they're going to be producing it.
They might just be background characters,
they might not be main characters.
also the fact that Bernal is in it makes it sound like
Marvel is going to be doing Werewolf by night
any time soon.
the original Boys comic book that this is based on
didn't run that long.
There are still a ton of characters from the comic book
that they have not featured on the TV shows yet.
Like there's a version of Spider-Man from the Boys
comic book that they're finally going to be doing
during the boys Season four called a Web Weaver.
so there's still a lot
a lot of major Marvel and DC characters
that they can parody on all these different boys.
Spinoff series like the Gen V-Series are mostly based
on X-Men characters.
but because this is largely going
to be taking place in Mexico.
The original boys
comic book does not travel to Mexico that much.
It's not really referenced that much.
They're couple international places.
They travel in the comics, like on the TV show.
They adapted some of that during the boys season three
when they found Jensen Ackles soldier Boy character
that was being held
captive in Russia, being experimented on by Soviets
eventually the Russians
after the fall of the Soviet Union in the comics
there was a large stash of superheroes
that was hiding out in Russia.
but generally, all this stuff
that they're doing in Mexico seems pretty fresh.
So it seems like a lot of the stuff that they'll be
either borrowing from other parts of the comic book
and just changing it so that it's happening in Mexico
or just creating a bunch of new characters.
they also did that for the Gen V TV show,
like it's loosely
based on the G men from the original Boys comic book,
but they wanted to make the TV series a little younger
skewing like more of a Y type of series.
so they gave it the college
setting to be more of a parody of the classic X-Men
movies with Professor X's School
for gifted youngsters with the twist that
because this is Vought, who runs the school
and they're super evil, the school doesn't admit kids
so that they can learn to be better superheroes
or learn to even make more money.
it admits then to the school so that it can study them.
It only admits students
who are either high profile enough to help them raise
more money for Vought or they have powers
that are unique enough or powerful enough
that wants to try and replicate them
or use their powers for some sinister purpose.
Mostly that purpose just boils back to them.
Making more money for Vought, the company,
whatever it takes
to make another dollar for the company,
anything to boost that share price.
so you can guess the basic
premise of the boys in Mexico
is that Vought
probably has international arms of the company
that manage superheroes in other countries
like Homelander spent a lot of time outside the U.S.
during conflicts in the East.
Turns out, though,
he was responsible for a lot of that, that was all part
of their early storyline with him
trying to get superheroes in the military.
in Homelander was secretly giving compound V
to terrorists
using A-Train to run it across the country,
literally run it across the country.
so that it would create a panic in the military,
the government and they would allow
lots of superheroes in the military.
But then they kind of got off on that plan
and they got on to the temporary compound B plan
because that was way more efficient for them.
ways you're to make money on this temporary compound.
B, but here's the thing with Vought
having a lot of testing labs like facilities in Mexico
up to this point, like the boys season for Vought,
previously he controlled all Compound B
in all superheroes, keeping them, for the most part,
within the United States.
they're couple exceptions like United States
superheroes traveling internationally,
earlier on the series, we saw some of the United States
hidden testing facilities where they would stash
superheroes or just experiment on them.
will probably learned during the Boys
Mexico series that there are way bigger,
way worse ones in Mexico because the laws are way
easier on companies like Vought.
Also, they're exploiting cheap labor down there
because that would do something like that
There are a lot of Real-Life Evil companies
that do stuff like that in Vought
might just be using Mexican citizens
as cannon fodder for their experiments.
but because it is meant to be a superhero TV show
or a parody of a superhero TV show,
they're probably going to be
a couple of Mexican superheroes
rising out of that to survive the process
and also maybe some superheroes down there.
They got their compound on the black market
and have just been trying to stay off of its radar
this whole time.
so they don't send homelander into laser,
all of them like they did at the end of the show.
Homelander is like what's break glass
in case of emergency
kind of contingency plan like if things get too bad
just calling Homelander and just have him
laser stuff squish stuff, step on step
do anything just to get rid of problems.
laser, all your problems away. but.
Unlike the Gen V show, we don't know
quite as much about the actual boys Mexico plot.
Like, what will they actually be doing during the show?
What's the overarching mystery on Gen V?
That was basically the woods
like learning about the woods.
They exist then dealing with the massive
break out in chaos caused by it.
the only major Hispanic superheroes
that we've seen on the boys so far that I can think of
are supersonic who got squished by Homelander
Mickey, rest in peace and maybe Blue Hawk.
technically, this would be the third spinoff because
they did the Boys Diabolical Anthology series first.
If you haven't seen that,
I would recommend checking it out.
It's actually pretty solid.
some of the episodes are canon to the boys main series.
Some of them are not Canon making Gen V
the second spinoff that they did.
They did confirmed
that Gen V is going to get a season two.
They're working on it
now. It's going to be called sophomore year.
Unofficially in Eric Kripke,
the showrunner for the Boys main show,
said that it will run past five seasons.
Originally he had a five year plan.
He said they had to rewrite his ending
because he decided to push it way past that.
I'm guessing if they're lucky,
they'll make it to like season seven.
We'll see.
but let me know in the comments if they're going to be
doing a completely separate storyline down in Mexico.
What do you want
Vought in other superheroes to be doing
during the events of the series,
like what do you want the actual mystery to be?
Generally, it usually flows from Vought.
Explore guiding people
In generally one of the major differences,
especially one of the reasons
why companies go to Mexico, is because
the laws are way
looser on what companies can do and get away with.
My only real concern with all these boys spin offs
that they've been announcing
is that hopefully they don't get to the point
where they turn into the thing that they're parodying.
Like the Boys is meant to be a direct parody of Marvel.
DC Like everything they're doing, all the Marvel Phase
four stuff, people have been clowning on for a while.
the whole idea that Marvel has been doing spin off
series for like anybody and everybody.
Everybody gets a series like Oprah,
just giving away series for every single character
from the comics in No joke right after Disney
Plus launched a couple of years ago,
the boys released a funny in-universe promo for Vought
plus clowning on
that like years, all the giant glut of content
that you probably don't care about.
But we're going to provide.
Plus, plus, plus, plus
Sign up now.
so we haven't quite got there with all the boys
spinoffs yet, but hopefully we don't get to the point
where there's like five or six or seven spin offs.
I don't think that it can sustain
that many different spinoffs before
it turns into the thing that it is parodying.
we have been pretty lucky with the boys spin offs.
So far they've been pretty solid. Gen V was solid.
The boys diabolical was pretty solid.
Hopefully
the Boys Mexico Series is also just as good. But.
Let me know in the comments if there's any other boys
spinoffs potentially that they do.
What do you want them to do
based on the original comics?
I'll do more videos for the series.
As soon as we start getting some more teasers,
it'll probably be a little while ago, but
we should get a boys Season four trailer this weekend,
which is why
I think they actually released the news about the Boys
Mexico spinoff
because they're doing this big Boys Season four panel
this weekend, whatever they wind up dropping.
Of course, I will do a video for it.
It should be Sunday, I think.
I'm not sure it will be sometime this weekend.
This scene is of homelander at a rally
and based on the butcher teaser,
this actually looks like it's them
winning the election.
Victoria Neuman and Robert Singer winning the election
in superheroes, getting into the White House.
the look on Homelander's face basically
makes it seem like he feels metaphorically invincible.
Like literally he's meant to feel invincible
because as far as we know, there's
nothing on the planet that could actually hurt him
in a really dangerous kind of way.
Like people have gotten close to it.
They made it seem like they could potentially hurt him,
but he's never really been hurt.
Like, for instance, maybe shove the pencil in his ear.
He's already healed that damage.
Like that's how quickly he heals.
maybe, maybe Victoria Neuman's compound
virus will be able to affect him in some way,
but I don't think that it will be.
I think that's the whole idea.
Like they want to make it seem like it's dangerous to
all the superheroes, but he's meant to be so powerful
that it won't affect him,
at least affect him in the same way.
So he'll basically be like,
Fine, there's nothing you can do to stop me.
Like you tried to out me as this terrible person
with the video of the plane.
the butcher teaser. Did they release?
Seems like him standing around
in the aftermath of this election night party
with his side, Basically,
like Victoria Neuman gets into office?
I see the other side.
Technically, Homelander
doesn't really like Victoria Neuman,
But the whole idea is that she used to be doing this.
Like this whole campaign push
was to get Vought superheroes in the White House
to get control of the White House.
she kind of went rogue on the plan at the end, like she
made an alliance with Homelander against Stan Edgar.
so even though they don't really like each other,
they made an alliance temporarily
so that she can win the White House.
I think the whole idea that you're going to try to use
this compound be superhero virus
to get out from under his thumb,
so to speak, like somehow break away from Homelander
some of the other homelander scenes at the end of Gen
V were meant to set up.
The beginning of season four, like I said, is
going to take place like days after the end of the Gen
V finale,
basically him cleaning up that mess at the university.
But I'm wondering if any of the Gen V characters
will show up during the boys season four.
Like there's already so much going on, so we might not
see most of them until Gen V season two.
there are couple new characters
that we've learned about.
I already talked about Tech Night during my Gen V
episodes.
He's still alive, still loving all the holes
that he can find, sticking it in every single hole
that he can get his hands on.
We know that Jeffrey Dean
Morgan is going to be playing a brand new character.
He's working with Butcher here.
So I'm guessing that he's part of the government
or part of some black ops agency,
and that's how he gets into the story.
make sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
Click Here for that Boys Season 4 Trailer Video
I'll update the link as soon as I post that and click here
for all my other boys videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!